oh dang
what's up everybody it's warren got with
me today and chris from cosmic culture
the shang chi and the legends of the 10
rings official trailer
just watched we're gonna watch it for
the first time we got the teaser
now the full thing hopefully learn a
little bit more about it but let's go
10 rings right on my life
the 10 rings gave our family power
if you wanted them to be yours one day
you have to show me you are strong
enough to carry them
oh that's cool yeah john
you are a product of all who came before
you
the legacy of your family you are your
mother
and whether you like it or not you are
also your father
i told my men they wouldn't be able to
kill me if they tried
who murders people be careful how you
speak to me
start a new life
but i could never escape his shadow
my son you can't run from your past
oh dang
is this what you wanted yeah
you got this abomination
it said abomination it is abomination
go back go back no no no no
more back no this right here yeah it's
right here
abomination roars look
oh my gosh so yeah with the subtitles on
it says abomination no that's him
that's crazy that was a sweet trailer
i'm surprised they threw him in the
trailer they just threw him in the tree
i mean i guess they announced that he's
coming back and she hulk which means
this links to [ __ ]
so he's gonna like escape somehow but
wow okay so they gave us like the full
thing in this one
um that was really cool at the end it
looked like maybe
he had five rings yeah like maybe at
some point he had some and his dad had
some of them when we had some of them
um looks like his mom's going to be
involved since this is going to be
we saw the dragon who is an untitled
dragon at this point
right now uh they're not going with the
classic name but
uh we saw the dragon we sold this is so
weird
i saw that i was like whoa um but
awesome
uh wow it looks like this movie is gonna
be pretty visually
like oh it's gonna be like really cool
you saw like they're sitting there by
the water
and then you have all you know the kung
fu mixed with like some type of
abilities like moving all the nature
around them and stuff like that
the fight scenes are going to be nuts
i'm just super excited for marvel meets
kung fu yeah i love such awful movies
i've stated plenty of times
especially my review about black widow
hand hand combat i love hand-to-hand
combat
and that's what this is going to be with
some weapons thrown in the rings
and uh it's gonna be nice to like um i
was gonna say
have them have a movie that's like not
all like shooting stuff like that
but i'm sure there will be some powers
with the rings and stuff like that but
the rings look super op i'm actually
glad they made them
like rings on the arms because it looks
visually better
super cool so um yeah i'm excited for
this movie i've been excited since they
announced it but this got me even more
hype
this is the best trailer they've dropped
for out of all yeah promotions
and on top of that i'm excited for
movies
yeah we haven't gotten a phase four
movie just yet black widow's around the
corner i love the disney plus shows but
there is definitely something that i
miss about
picking up again yeah i'm excited for
that too i like the movies picking up
again
and the hype is is bigger is a lot
bigger
it's bigger yeah so but all right i'll
do my breakdown tomorrow
um i want to go through this it looks
like there's a lot to actually break
down
so if you're not subscribed to chris
over at custom culture do that
roommate you also edits for cosmic
wonder so
another version of me um and yeah
see you tomorrow from breakdown woof